hi this is international master David
Bruce for chest comm and today you are
going to learn absolutely one of the
most important strategic elements of
chess which is how to win material and
in chess there are various different
kinds of advantages you can have at any
point in time and the most obvious the
most common the most significant is a
material advantage which just means
having more pieces or more valuable
pieces than what your opponent has and
I'd also want to be easiest kinds of
advantages to convert so it's very
important to know about this and there
will be another video about how to
convert it when you have a material
advantage but today I'm going to tell
you the three ways generally speaking
that you will win material the first way
is more tactical than strategic
it's basically just that you have to
stay alert all the time for tactical
opportunities so I've chosen a set of
examples from a super tournament meaning
a tournament where super grandmasters
were playing and super grandmasters are
grandmasters who are really highly rated
like in the top 30 or 40 in the world so
these guys are really really good but
watch what happens here how white wins
material black has just played their
knight c6 attacking white's rook white
backs up the rook black plays a normal
move here Age 5 securing the Queen's
position by controlling g4 typical
positional move and I'm giving his King
an extra square and now white pounced
with 97 and this move attacks the night
which is defending the rook while
opening up the attack of these two rooks
and you'll see that however black plays
here they're going to lose a rook for a
knight for example if they take white's
rook here white can take this rook with
check right and then recapture on d2
which will leave white with a queen and
rook against the queen a knight or has
happened the game black took the knight
and then white took the rook and white
head rook versus Knight and went on to
convert this game and win the tournament
that was a 10-buck row playing white
and now our next example which is of a
different kind which is that sometimes
you win material by building a
positional attack that your opponent
can't handle this is a really really
good way to win material and it might be
almost as common as just noticing your
opponent's tactical mistakes and jumping
on those
this can include when I say building a
positional attack your opponent can't
you know defend against this can include
an endgame where you've got one or two
pieces and you encircle a weak pawn you
attack it with your king and then you
shoulder their king away from that pawn
for too long him away and then you
capture one pawn that can be a winning
positional attack but here you have an
example that's more of a middle game and
here's how it goes why it has a queen
against two Brooks so it's a very
complicated position opposite colored
bishops increase the chances that you
can create a strong attack and black
hasn't yet got any good way to develop
this rook so white starts trying to
build up an attack so here's how he does
it he moves his queen attacking this
pond and also looking on this diagonal
black defends the pawn with rook d7 and
he's gonna want to try and keep this
Queen out from penetrating into his
position so she can attack things but
it's going to be hard to do so b5 check
is played black blocks with the rook I
believe black didn't block with the
knight because black wanted the rook to
be able to block on ei tiff Whitehead
brought the Queen in here aiming at this
square so black blocked with the rook
and white just plays a simple move just
calmly with his Bishop h6 by black H for
my white getting rid of a current made
black has a square for his rook now
though not an exciting one it was this
rook here and now white starts trying to
penetrate with the Queen first a me into
c8
but black just plays Bishop f5 because
the rook can block and come back and
forth like this
so now blacks preparing to move the Jeep
on to get his King out and his rook into
the game and now white switches the
bishop back here to attack and black is
unable to tangle the pieces so by plays
f6 trying to fight out this you a3 so
why it's already gonna win some material
it's gonna win the rook for his Bishop
and black took on e5 trying to activate
his own pass pawns here and Queen takes
pawn is a pretty decent move because
this pawn is fast but white played
something even better winning more
material check the King has to come up
and now Knight takes d5 attacking the
rook and extra time and this rook has
nowhere to escape because if it moves
back to e8 White has Queen d7 check and
wins material black has to block with
the knight I guess and white takes with
the night and if black takes the knight
in this position here white can take
with check right here and after this Y
can take take take and y is gonna win
even more material and that'll make the
endgame easy enough and if black does
something like pawn takes pawn after 95
white will take once and then pin the
knight with the Queen again creating an
attack that black just can't deal with
so that is another common way to win
material is you build up some kind of an
attack in this case on some dark squares
against a king with dis coordinated
pieces and when your opponent can't
quite cover your threats you're able to
win material against is somewhat dis
coordinated pieces now let's see an
example that's kind of a mix of those
two a mix of building a positional
attack and being alert for tactical
opportunities because really that's when
you're gonna win materials when you're
putting some pressure on your opponent
and then you're also alert to your
opportunities to her
them so in this position by the way that
last game was was won by Sergey Karjakin
who tied for first with buck crow and
this game here is also played by Kerry
Aachen these are the two games that he
won in the tournament so night of five
is played and you see White is in a
position where he's trying to exert some
pressure against these two squares in
blacks camps so white plays Knight at
five now black was afraid that if he
takes and white takes he can never
really deal with these two pieces here
he can't play g6 because of taking on f6
so this Queens on a really nice square
here it's hard to just lodge this bishop
and this Knight will join the attack
later
so black doesn't give up his life
squared bishop and plays queen to e6 but
that gets him into something even worse
Kuryakin alertly plays Bishop to h6
targeting g7 and first of all black
can't take it because Queen g3 Czech
king over and checkmate or Knight g4
check here and now there are a number of
decent moves for white but 97 Czech it's
pretty much what's going to happen here
probably King g7 Knight takes c6 Bishop
takes d4 Knight f8 and White has a
winning endgame so he strikes with
Bishop h6 attacking the g7 pawn and
likely Knight takes e4 his other
possible defense would be the knight
coming back to be 8 to defend g7 and in
that case white would just move his
Queen over to attack g7 again and now g7
can only be defended further by the
Queen if you played g6 white will
capture the rook so if the Queen defense
this way 97 wins the Queen so let's look
at Queen f6 now White has the move
Bishop g5 cleverly switching directions
Queen moves back here and then Bishop e7
and white traps this rook winning
material
so the game went Knight takes e4 and
white played Queen to g4 if white just
captures this Knight he's losing his own
knight on f5 right and losing his attack
against g7 so white has to calculate
that he'll continue the attack here
threatening checkmate and blacks only
defense against the g7 square at this
point was g6 and so white now toke on e4
with the knight black takes here to
recover the PCs down and white will
trade Queens now and then pick up the
rook on f8 at the end and white easily
won this endgame and then tied for first
in the tournament now there's a third
quite common way to win material which
has perhaps more to do with your
opponent than with you and it goes like
this here is the game White has been
positionally out playing black with a
nice knight on c6 a light square this is
another different way you can play
opposite colored bishops you put your
knight on a nice light square where this
Bishop can't attack it but it controls
all these dark squares and so white has
actually managed to shut in and make
black's bishop a really bad piece you
see with this nice knight placement here
on top of that he's advanced a nice
majority in the center gaining a lot of
space there so White has a very very
nice position and at this point he
played h3 trying to kick the knight back
to h6 and sort of continue to send the
black pieces back in abject retreat and
at some point when you push your
opponent and push your opponent of
building up your advantage a lot of
people rather than letting their pieces
all get pushed back to bad squares are
going to sacrifice material in order to
stay active at least good players are
going to do this so these being super
gems black didn't retreat his knight he
played rook takes g3 H takes g4 and now
you see you've got a situation where
White has a piece against two pawns but
of course it's a messy position where
his Kings a bit exposed and black has
some
play now what do you do when your
opponent sacks material you capture it
but you better be ready to defend well
and white was and did eventually win
this game but this is another way to win
material basically you push your
opponent back to the wall until they
refuse to keep backing up and they sack
material to try and stay active and
that's definitely one of the hardest
kinds of material it managed to convert
because by definition your opponent's
probably active and making threats
against you but it's one of the most
common ways to win material so be aware
that that is coming up in your games I
hope you enjoyed this video and I'll see
you around on chess calm